hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live was in der Silvesternacht in Berlin
und anderen Städten passiert ist das
muss uns heute noch beschäftigen
Angriffe auf Menschen die anderen helfen
Einsatzkräfte wurden attackiert
Feuerwehrleute und Rettungskräfte in
Kranken und Notarztwagen unfassbare
Bilder wie hier aus Berlin wir schauen
zusammen rein
hier wurde auf ein fahrenden
Rettungswagen ein
feuerlöschergeschleudert die Scheibe die
hier zum Glück stand aber das ist
passiert an dem Abend Beschuss auf
Menschen mit Böller und Raketen Beschuss
auf Einsatzkräfte das war nicht nur in
Berlin sondern auch in anderen Städten
eine traurige Wahrheit und wie die
Einsatzkräfte diese Nacht erlebt haben
und woher diese Gewalt kommt das ist
heute unser Thema wenn ihr dazu live
kommentieren oder Fragen stellen wollt
macht das direkt bei uns im Stream oder
per Mail denn wir haben uns gestern
spannende Gäste eingeladen und wollen
zuerst sprechen mit Thomas Kirstein er
ist der Sprecher der Berliner Feuerwehr
steht vor uns vor der Feuerwache in
Steglitz und war in der Silvester Nacht
selbst im Einsatz in Berlin schönen
guten Abend
ja einen schönen guten Abend nach Mainz
Herr Kirstein wir haben erste Bilder
gesehen eben gerade im Einspieler aber
sie waren selbst vor Ort können Sie uns
berichten was sie selbst vor Ort in
Berlin in der Silvesternacht erlebt
haben
ja ich war in einer großen Einsatzstelle
in der Germania Promenade im Einsatz
dort hat ein Dachstuhl gebrannt und wir
hatten schon als
pressedienstinformation darüber dass
einige Fahrzeuge angegriffen worden sind
wir haben auch ein Bild relativ früh auf
Twitter veröffentlicht auch so ein
bisschen mit dem Appell man möge uns
nicht angreifen und an dieser
Einsatzstelle bin ich auf einen
Löschfahrzeug getroffen was auf dem Weg
zu diesem Großbrand auf der
Hermannstraße in Neukölln angegriffen
wurde sie mussten an einer Barrikade
halten die gebrannt hat und
verlangsamten die Fahrt und nur aus dem
ja als wie abgesprochen ist eine riesige
Personengruppe von bis zu 30 vermummten
vermummten Tätern auf dieses
Löschfahrzeug gestürzt hat versucht mit
Schreckschusswaffen
vorgeschreck abzuheuern auf die
Frontscheibe die Gerätefächer wurden
probiert zu öffnen oder wohnen geöffnet
das wohngeräte rausgenommen und es wurde
sogar versucht in die Mannschaftskabine
Feuerwerkskörper zu werfen das ist eine
ganz neue Dimension von Aggressivität
gegen Einsatzkräfte und deswegen haben
wir die auch jetzt so offensiv
veröffentlicht
sie sprechen von einer neuen Dimension
also das bedeutet sowas haben sie noch
nie zuvor erlebt
ja auch dieser Angriff auf den
Rettungswagen mit einem Feuerlöscher auf
die Frontscheibe das sind Dinge die wir
so in dieser Art nicht kennen auch nicht
diese Absprachen die es vermeintlich gab
wir haben mehrfach die Schilderung von
Einsatzkräften bekommen dass sie das
Gefühl hatten sie wohnen extra in einen
Hinterhalt gelockt mussten ihre Fahrt
verlangsamt und dann wie aus dem Nichts
kam Täter mehrere Täter und haben
gezielt diese Feuerwehrfahrzeuge
beschossen wir waren es gewohnt in der
Vergangenheit dass auf Einsatzfahrten
ist immer wieder zu beschissen kam aber
nicht in dieser Dimension und auch nicht
mit dieser Aggressivität ja auch gerade
gesehen ein Täter der abgeführt wurde es
sollen bis zu 103 Menschen festgenommen
worden sein darunter 98 Männer fünf
Frauen wer hat sie denn angegriffen sie
sprechen von vermummten dass es
natürlich dann schwer zuzuordnen aber
sind sie heute jetzt schon ein bisschen
schlauer woher von wem kamen diese
Angriffe
also die Ermittlungen übernimmt ja die
Polizei Berlin so gut es möglich ist
wahrscheinlich weil die natürlich auch
sehr schnell geflüchtet sind es sind
heute in den sozialen Medien Videos
aufgetaucht wo das auch zu sehen ist
dass sie sehr schnell auf dieses
Fahrzeug zulaufen dann wieder weg rennen
es ist vermutlich schwer diese
Täterinnen und Täter überhaupt Ding fest
zu machen was wir heute dann noch mal
besonders festgestellt haben in den
sozialen Medien dass diese Videos von
beschüssen auf Einsatzfahrzeuge sogar
noch mit Musik untertitelt werden und
mehr oder weniger ja verherrlicht das
können wir nicht nachvollziehen das
finden wir nicht in Ordnung
zumal eben auch einige Einsatzkräfte
selbst verletzt worden sind bei
natürlich diesem Einsatz wie werden denn
Betroffene Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
da jetzt letzte Nacht unterwegs waren im
Zweifel verletzt worden sind wie werden
die dann betreut von ihrer Seite wie ja
wir begleiten Sie die vielleicht auch um
mit solchen Erfahrungen umzugehen
ja in erster Linie muss man sagen dass
der Krisenstab der Feuerwehr morgens
neuer morgens nachdem wir diese
schlimmen Schilderung erhalten haben
noch mal sehr offensiv die Angebote der
Einsatz Nachsorge kommuniziert haben wir
haben sogenannte Einsatz Nachsorge Teams
und wir sind jetzt in den Tagen auch
dabei die Führungskräfte zu
sensibilisieren Angebote wahrzunehmen
auch für ihre Einsatzkräfte denn die
Einsatzkräfte die wir in der Nacht in
der gehört haben die ihre Schilderungen
an uns geteilt haben die waren alle sehr
mitgenommen das sind Erlebnisse waren
auch erfahrene Einsatzkräfte die so
etwas noch nicht erlebt hatten und tief
betroffen waren und wenn wir beim Thema
Verletzungen sind wir haben heute morgen
mit der Pressestelle der Feuerwehr
Hamburg telefoniert wir fliegen ein sehr
eng Austausch und dort haben wir eine
Nachricht erhalten die uns einfach nur
schmerzt und zutiefst traurig macht ein
Angehöriger der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr
Hamburg ist so schwer verletzt worden
durch einen pyrobeschuss dass er auf
einem Auge jetzt im Moment um das
Augenlicht kämpft wir sind
Feuerwehrfamilie wir wünschen an dieser
Stelle aus Berlin alles alles Gute wir
denken an ihn und man muss sich vor
Augen halten es handelt sich um
freiwillige Feuerwehrleute die
ehrenamtlich ja ehrenamtlich und
freiwillig für die Gesellschaft nicht zu
Hause Silvester feiern sondern die
Sicherheit der Gesellschaft
sicherstellen wollen und dann noch
angegriffen werden das macht uns einfach
nur sprach und fassungslos
ja unfassbar und natürlich liegt die
Frage nach haben sie selbst haben die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen überhaupt noch
Lust auf diesen Job wenn es da jetzt
darum geht auch seine eigene Gesundheit
sein Leben noch über sage ich mal die
Gefahr hinaus die man sowieso schon
eingeht zu riskieren
man muss sagen dass diese
Feuerwehrfamilie dieser Teamgeist sehr
viel aufhängt man muss sich vor Augen
halten dass das Löschfahrzeug was dort
in höchster Gefahren man muss es so
sagen höchster Lebensgefahr durch diesen
Angriff auch war die Fahrt zur
Einsatzstelle weitergeführt hat ja und
dann drei Stunden lang ein
Dachstuhlbrand gelöscht hat auch im Team
und man muss sagen dass wir als
Kommunikationsabteilung auch ein Stück
weit das so sehen dass wenn wir diese
Angriffe öffentlich machen das ein Stück
weit auch die Menschen die für uns im
Einsatz sind ja durch die Gesellschaft
einen Rückhalt halten uns haben sehr
viele Nachrichten heute erreicht die
sagen das geht gar nicht wir sind auf
eurer Seite das ist können wir nicht
nachvollziehen und das hilft dem einen
oder anderen und was wäre denn etwas was
Ihnen helfen würde also was fordern Sie
konkret vielleicht für die Zukunft um
eben ihre Sicherheit mehr zu
gewährleisten
man muss einfach feststellen dass wir
letztes Jahr als es einen Verkaufsverbot
für Feuerwerk gab wir sehr wenig
Angriffe und sehr wenig Brände hatten
und jeder Brand jede Verletzung und wir
es gab auch dieses Jahr im Bundesgebiet
schlimme Verletzungen bei Kindern man
muss sich vor Augen halten 30 Prozent
der Verletzten durch Feuerwerkskörper
sind gar nicht diejenigen die das
Feuerwerk selber abschießen sondern sind
betroffen als umherstehen entweder
Kinder oder andere Erwachsene und man
muss sich das immer vor Augen halten
dass das vielleicht ohne den ein oder
anderen Feuerwerkskörper gar nicht
passiert wäre insofern ist es für uns
als Feuerwehr können wir nur sagen jeder
Feuerwerkskörper in einer in der Hand
von Menschen ist ein Stück weit
gefährlich und wenn die Menschen dann
noch unter Alkohol Einfluss sind so wie
es in der Silvesternacht auf der Fall
ist dann passieren Unfälle die
vielleicht vermeidbar werden
also ihre konkrete Forderungen an die
Politik dann ein böllerverbot verstehe
ich verstehe ich sie da so richtig
also ein Bella verboten muss man
kontrollieren und wir haben festgestellt
in Berlin wir haben drei
böllerverbotszonen und die Polizei
Berlin hat dort einen sehr hohen
Personaleinsatz auffahren müssen um
diese böllerverbotszonen sicher zu
machen ein böllerverbot muss überwacht
werden vielleicht ist es auch ein Ziel
oder es wäre wünschenswert dass wir auch
mal den Blick in die Welt gehen es gibt
große Metropolen Sydney oder Paris wo es
geplant der Feuerwerke gibt von
Fachleuten wo die Menschen sich dieses
Feuerwerk ansehen können
eine Idee einen Vorschlag von Thomas
kirster in der Sprecher der Berliner
Feuerwehr heute nach dem Einsatz noch
mal sich die Zeit genommen bei uns zu
Gast vielen Dank dafür
ja
und auch aus der Politik wurde sich
heute natürlich geäußert nach diesen
Ereignissen Innenministerin ferser
spricht von einer Verrohung und setzt
auf Zitat konsequentes Handeln schärfere
Gesetze braucht es aber demnach jetzt
ihrer Meinung nicht denn die sein ja
schon vorhanden wir schauen uns dazu
eine Zusammenfassung ein Bericht an von
Henriette de Maiziere
es sind diese verstörenden Bilder der
Silvesternacht die die Hauptstadt auch
an Tag 2 des neuen Jahres beschäftigen
wo das Feiern in Gewalt eskalierte wo
polizei und Rettungskräfte massiv
angegriffen wurden die
bundesinnenministerin teilt schriftlich
mit das ist ein Ausmaß an Gewalt das
fassungslos und wütend macht und es
zeigt eine Verrohung die konsequentes
Handeln erfordert den Sicherheitskräften
blieb teils nur der Rückzug ein Mann
wirft einen Feuerlöscher auf einen
Rettungswagen die Scheibe hält der
Stahlflasche stand die Polizei kann den
Werfer festnehmen Gewalt in bisher nicht
bekanntem Ausmaß die Polizei hatte genau
das befürchtet und Maßnahmen gefordert
es gab kein generelles böllerverbot es
ist Aufgabe des Bundesministerium für
inneren hier das Sprengstoffgesetz zu
novellieren anzupacken dass es nicht
geschehen und die Länder insbesondere
Kommunen haben sich mit Verbotszonen
geholfen die mal besser mal schlechter
gewirkt haben
Berlin gab es mehr als 100 Festnahmen
auch in anderen Städten Angriffe auf
Rettungskräfte wer die Täter sind
darüber gibt es heute keine konkreten
Angaben wir haben es hier mit einem Teil
der Bevölkerung zu tun den die den Staat
und auch den Vertretern des Staates
distanziert gegenüberstehen die nicht
recht erkennen wie wichtig es ist auch
bestimmte Normen in Bezug auf Gewalt
einzuhalten und in diesem Sinne werden
dann Feuerwehr Rettungskräfte und auch
Polizei als repräsentan gestartetes
angegriffen das neue Jahr kämpft mit
alten Problemen die Silvesternacht 2022
23 der Staat auch in die Diskussion wie
künftig Silvester gefeiert wird nicht
nur in Berlin sondern in ganz
Deutschland
auf viele von uns wirkt das komplett
irrational das Menschen angegriffen
werden die einem selbst oder anderen
helfen wollen ich habe auch in die
Kommentare bei euch geschaut hatte
gelesen hier sogar von jemanden jetzt
finde ich den Kommentar glaube ich nicht
mehr aber dass jemand sagte ihm kommen
die Tränen in die Augen bei den
Schilderungen unseres Feuerwehrmanns
eben also auf viele von uns wird das
wirklich eben komplett absurd aber wir
wollen ja heute auch darüber sprechen
warum macht man sowas war wie wie kann
sowas passieren und haben uns dazu jetzt
noch in der zweiten Hälfte ein Gast
eingeladen der Antworten für uns hat
Professor Dr Andreas Zick gewaltforscher
von der Uni Bielefeld schönen guten
Abend
genau absurd das helfende angegriffen
werden so erscheint ist einigen auch in
den Kommentaren also überhaupt nicht zu
verstehen brennende Barrikaden die wir
gesehen haben aus einer Silvesternacht
eigentlich an der Situation wo Menschen
miteinander feiern wollen und dann
eskaliert das so wie können sie sich das
erklären sie beschäftigen sich schon so
lange mit diesem Phänomen wann eskaliert
Gewalt was haben sie für Antworten für
uns auf diese Frage die wir alle nicht
so richtig verstehen
zunächst mal ist für die für Gruppen die
Gewalt gar nicht so irrational wie wir
denken sondern die Gewalt die wir
gesehen haben ist für sie ein Erlebnis
diese Silvesternacht ist ja schon im
Vorfeld von vielen sehr inszeniert
worden als endlich nach Corona können
wir wieder frei draußen knallen können
eine Party haben das heißt die
vorerwartung sind hochgegangen das
Nutzen Gruppen aus die dort dann eben
das Erlebnis inszenieren und für sie ist
das das Gewalt zeigen selbst ein
Erlebnis das stärkt die Gruppen die da
unterwegs sind und wir haben vermummte
gesehen das sind Gruppen die haben nicht
nicht nur sondern Feindbilder gegenüber
Polizei und Rettungsdienste werden als
stören Friede wahrgenommen und diese vor
Erwartung diese Voreinstellung spielen
eine große Rolle die Gruppen gehen dann
zu solchen öffentlichen Plätzen
da soll dann eine Party stattfinden
findet erstmal nicht so viel statt sie
treffen dort auf andere die zugucken die
dann zum Teil eben auch Handyaufnahmen
machen und erleben das Ganze gar nicht
als ein Angriff sondern als ein pures
Erlebnis und Gewalt schafft eben dann
solche traumgewinne und es sind Gruppen
die versuchen diesen Raum dann eben
durch solche Gewalt auch zu dominieren
die Polizei zu jagen die Rettungsdienste
zu jagen das ist eine
Konfliktkonstellation mit der rechnenden
will nicht weil wir denken immer die
individuelle Normen jeder weiß doch dass
wir Rettungsdienste nicht angreifen soll
aber die greift eben nicht weil in
diesen Situationen und wenn dann noch
Stress entsteht wird dann die Gewalt zu
nehmen die Aggression daran orientiere
ich mich und das sind unterschiedliche
Gruppen die dann bei der Eskalation
beitragen das sind ja nicht nur die
einzelnen Täter wir werden jetzt sehen
das sind viele junge Männer dabei von
denen dann auch umstehende genau das
erwarten dass sie sich so inszenieren
das sind aber eben viele Zuschauerinnen
Zuschauer dabei andere die das Kandieren
die das dann in den sozialen Medien
hochladen dann wird das Ganze eben wie
wir gerade gehört haben in
Hochgeschwindigkeit weiter inszeniert
als ein riesengroßer Event und wir
müssen uns jetzt über Polizeibilder
unterhalten verrohm müssen wir genau
definieren was verroht da eigentlich in
der Gesellschaft aber es fällt nicht aus
dem Himmel wir haben seit einigen Jahren
einen Anstieg dieser ich sag mal
vorurteilsbasierten hasstaten und es
gibt eben massives der Type und
Vorurteile gegenüber den Diensten die
werden gar nicht mehr als
Rettungsdienste wahrgenommen sondern als
Dienstleister die ihren Job machen
sollen und möglichst nicht stören sollen
ich habe eure Kommentare wiedergefunden
und dazu eben gleich mehr aber zunächst
mal hier alles Alabaster nice schreibt
sehr entsetzt von den Bildern selber bin
ich Notfallsanitäter und habe sowas noch
nie erlebt Squeeze schreibt dieser Mob
hat einfach keine Angst mehr vor
juristischen Konsequenzen wenn die Täter
ermittelt werden dann wird doch
höchstens mal auf die Finger gehauen
glauben sie damit ist es erklärt also
keine Angst vor juristischen
Konsequenzen sie haben gerade eben auch
erwähnt das geht darum wie werden
rettungssanitäterinnen Sanitäter aber
grundsätzlich auch Rettungskräfte Beamte
im Einsatz wahrgenommen also ist das
auch ein ein Teil der Antwort keine
Angst vor juristischen Konsequenzen
mehr solange die Täter in der Gruppe
handeln und es sind in der Regel
Kleingruppen die sich da zusammentun die
rumlaufen und die versuchen eben Gewalt
auszuüben das als als sehr positiv
erleben und das auch noch spaßig wenn
und so weiter und es ist nicht unbedingt
ein Mob der dann irgendwie alle Normen
verliert sondern es ist eine es ist eine
Gruppendynamik in der dann Gruppen auch
bestätigt werden und der dann die Gewalt
erzeugt die Zugehörigkeit sobald die
Täter vor Gericht stehen bereuen sie
sagen sie ich weiß selber gar nicht wie
ich in die Situation hineinkommen konnte
das liegt dem daran dass sie das tun als
Gruppen und diese Gewalt auf einmal in
der Situation Zugehörigkeit schafft das
ist schwer nachzuvollziehen aber ich
glaube wir kennen solche Gewalt
Inszenierung aus den Fußballstadien wir
kennen sie bei vielen
Großveranstaltungen wir haben gesehen
auch bei den Corona Demonstrationen die
Gewalt die Berliner Polizei hat das zum
Glück mal Dokument ist dort auch
angestiegen und es zeigt etwas über das
Bild von eben Polizei und
Rettungsdiensten es zeigt auch etwas
darüber dass bremsfaktoren in der
Situation fehlen wir haben ja auch die
Kölner Silvesternacht noch vor Augen in
der sexualisierte Gewalt passiert ist
die wir auch nicht einfach erklären
können durch bestimmte Gruppen die dafür
alles verantwortlich sind das sind
Gruppendynamiken und die vorerwartung
werden diese Silvesternacht gleichzeitig
mit dieser Aufrüstung durch Feuerwehr
wir konnten ja alle zusehen wie viel
dort gekauft wurde und das Feuerwerk ist
immer professioneller geworden
da wird nicht im Vorfeld abgeschätzt ob
das zu Gewalt führen kann sondern wir
alle denken so ist Silvesterfeuerwerk
gehört dazu dass definieren weil es Teil
unserer Freiheit in Deutschland jeder
kann Feuerwerk zünden und diese
vorerwartung Blenden aus eine Erwartung
von Gewalt
und da sicherlich fehlen dann eben auch
die präventiven Bremskräfte für die
Gewalt aber müssen eben die
Gruppendynamik verstehen und da greifen
einfache Erklärungen nicht
männlichkeitsideale spielen eine Rolle
es sind vor allen Dingen junge Männer
die dort die Taten ausführen aber müssen
eben auch verstehen da sind im
Hintergrund immer andere die motivieren
die dann Selbstwert geben dies gut
finden diesen sozialen Medien weiter
transportieren und das sind diese
Faktoren die wir dann eben als
Verrohung im gesellschaftlichen
betrachten wir haben ja ich will kurz
nachfragen vor allem junge Männer sagen
sie ich habe hier auch schon häufiger
noch mehr Vermutung über die Herkunft
bei uns in den Kommentaren gelesen
möchte eine Frage von der fraxen hier
stellen gibt es offizielle
Verlautbarungen das überwiegend Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund beteiligt
waren so wie es eine große Tageszeitung
heute schreibt will er wissen
nein wir haben im Moment die Daten nicht
wir wissen das wird ja immer diskutiert
wir haben gesehen Berlin Neukölln war so
ein Hotspot wo viel Gewalt passiert ist
nun wird aber die Herkunft das alleine
in dich erklären Herkunft müssen wir
dann mal definieren da müssen wir sagen
gibt es bestimmt
Persönlichkeitseigenschaften
Dispositionen die dann mit Herkunft
verbunden sind in der Regel sind die
Täter haben auch alle in deutschen Pass
das sind deutsche Staatsbürger aber
natürlich sind das solche Räume die dann
definiert werden von den Gruppen das
sind unsere Räume und wir verteidigen
diese Räume und bei Silvester machen wir
uns einen Spaß in der Verteidigung indem
wir mit Feuerwerkskörpern angreifen das
sind Gruppen die sich dann zum Teil auf
Herkunft berufen wo wir dann aber
deutlich sagen müssen nein so einfach
funktioniert das nicht wenn wir mal
Gruppen nach
aggressionsorientierung unterscheiden
würden es gibt viele Studien die zeigen
das Spielen männlichkeitsrollen Bilder
spielen dann eine Rolle und wir haben
auch viele Täter die dann
Einwanderungsgeschichte haben die oft
viel leichter von Polizeien festgehalten
werden weil die gar nicht damit rechnen
wir sehen jetzt Gruppen die dort
vermummt reingehen und sofort bei
Verfolgung aus dem Raum verschwinden
diese die wissen wie Polizei sich fällt
die Polizei auch jagen und das deutet
nicht darauf hin dass hier der
migrationsfaktor irgendein alleiniger
oder schwerwiegender Faktor ist es sind
eher eben Rollenbilder mit denen wir uns
beschäftigen müssen und wieso ist das
jetzt ausgerechnet an Silvester so
eskaliert möchte shape bei Youtube
wissen
weil ich glaube dass die ganzen
vorerwartung die wir alle hatten jetzt
kommt die große Party und jetzt
zeigen wir uns in der Öffentlichkeit wir
zeigen unsere Räume dass das Silvester
tatsächlich so zu einem Event 22 23
hochstilisiert wurde
ich habe eigentlich damit gerechnet als
ich gesehen habe wie viel Feuerwerk
verkauft wurde und dass diese
öffentlichen Räume immer wieder von
Gruppen jetzt aufgesucht werden weil man
mit Gewalt Raumgewinne schaffen will und
das sind Strategien auch von Gruppen
gewesen die im Vorfeld schon da sind da
wirkt auch Alkohol der ist dann ein Hemd
der wird aber oft auch bewusst
eingesetzt und insofern diese Silvester
22 23 hat eine Vorgeschichte die wir
jetzt verstehen müssen weil da liegen
dann auch die Faktoren die dann der
bessere Prävention schaffen das war in
Köln so wir haben in Köln vieles
umgestellt die Polizei ist anders
vorgegangen wir haben die zugestellt wir
haben Fluchtwege geschaffen wir müssen
darüber nachdenken wie welche
Alternative haben wir zu solchen
eskalationssituationen mit Feuerwerk
denn viele Leute stehen da dann wird
Feuerwerk gezündet das wird gegenseitig
überboten in dem Feuerwerk man kommt in
einen Überbietungswettbewerb und dann
passiert auf einmal eine Aggression die
als lustig dargestellt wird eine Rakete
die auf dem Balkon geschossen wird und
dann greift auf einmal dieses Ereignis
als für alle das das ist auf einmal die
Norm das machen wir jetzt auch und dann
eskaliert die Situation
und Steffen J schreibt etwas sehr wahres
denn das stimmt natürlich leider auch er
schreibt ich bin selbst seit vielen
Jahren bei der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr im
Rettungsdienst tätig leider gibt es
solche Ereignisse nicht im selben Ausmaß
schreibt er aber seit Jahren und nicht
nur an Silvester und das stimmt und wir
erinnern uns ja wahrscheinlich auch alle
an andere unfassbare Videos zum Beispiel
in Stuttgart 2020 haben wir einen
kleinen Einspieler auch vorbereitet das
war auch ein Video was durch die Presse
ging und zwar jetzt glaube ich hoffe ich
dass wir es sehen können in einen
Spieler außer es gibt ein technisches
Problem ich beschreibe aber noch mal
kurz für uns alle zur Erinnerung was
passiert ist also ein Polizist fixierte
einen Mann am Boden und plötzlich trat
ein anderer Mann den Polizist von hinten
um und Umstehenden haben dabei
applaudiert also das war nicht Silvester
auch eine unfassbare Situation und jetzt
mal zu der Frage eben also auch
außerhalb von Silvester passiert das ist
uns Professor Dr Zick jetzt wieder
zugeschaltet dann wäre das meine nächste
Frage an Sie also auch eine gewaltsam
außerhalb von Silvester woran liegt das
und der Gesellschaft was meinen sie
wieder da setzen sie noch mal neu an für
mich bitte wir haben sie gerade noch
nicht gehört
also das passiert in vielen Bereichen
wir haben es im Fußball oft lange gehabt
durch den die Hooligan Gewalt wo wir
dann Präventionskonzepte haben wir haben
es während der
corona-demonstrationen gesehen wir haben
das gesehen im Bereich der
vorteilsbasierten hasstaten
offensichtlich wird eben
gesellschaftlich greift unsere Norm das
Gewalt ein No-Go ist nicht so einfach
wie wir denken Gewalt wird
gerechtfertigt Gewalt wird als Event
betrachtet und gerade bei
Großereignissen wir haben auch viele
Konzerte gesehen wo Rettungsdienst eine
Weg versperrt wurde bzw sie dort als
Störung wahrgenommen wurden und dieses
Bild von den Diensten und das haben wir
ja im Einspieler auch durch den
Feuerwehrmann gesehen dass die Dienste
gar nicht als gemeindienste waren
genommen werden sondern als Service als
Dienstleistung das führt dann dazu dass
ich auch nicht helfend eingreife dass
ich eine Gasse Bilder dass ich nicht
versuche gew zu verhindern
und wir müssen halt feststellen dass wir
auch oft über die Gewalt die dann
passiert empört sind dann gucken wir uns
drum und sagen wer ist denn jetzt dafür
verantwortlich dann rufen wir wieder die
Ordnungskräfte auf die angegriffen
werden dann passiert wieder die
Diskussion mehr Polizei bessere
Videoüberwachung dass die Verfolgung und
Aufklärung und in ins fellfeld hinein
sehr wichtig ist auch präventiv wichtig
ist das ist ja
ungehalten aber wir haben eben auch zu
den Gewalt die da passiert wenig
alternativ Konzepte da kommen viele
Menschen in die brauchen einen
alternativ Konzept und die müssen eben
an die Normen erinnert werden wir denken
immer solche Normen die sind irgendwie
mit der Kindheit in den Schulen
beigebracht und dann ist es gut und dann
wissen wir ja alle um die Norm so
funktioniert das nicht Gesellschaften
verändern sich und wir stellen eben
jetzt fest dass wir viele Menschen haben
die eben diese
enorm gegen die Gewalt gar nicht haben
die das geht ja in Social Media weiter
also das das Weiterleiten von Videos vor
Polizeien angegriffen werden wird gar
nicht als Gewalt wahrgenommen von den
Opfern selber schon wenn sie sich dort
sehen wie sie angegriffen werden in
Social Media und da ist eine Distanz
auch eine zu große Distanz zwischen
Bevölkerung und dann eben den
rettenrettungs- und ordnungsdiensten und
welche Rolle spielt vielleicht auch die
Zivilgesellschaft also wir alle
drumherum
sie spielt eine große Rolle weil wenn
wir diskutieren mit Rettungsdienste mit
Feuerwehren mit Polizeien dann ist ein
wichtiger Faktor sie werden angegriffen
diese Angriffe werden dokumentiert die
werden in Social Media hochgeladen
darüber wird sich lustig gemacht und sie
erfahren eben keine Hilfe
Rettungsdienste brauchen für die Rettung
eben auch die Unterstützung und dieses
denken dass das irgendwie zusammen gehen
muss das ist nicht vorhanden das ist
auch im Vorfeld von Silvester wir haben
genau die Kölner Silvesternacht
analysiert und haben eben gesehen das
Bevölkerung gar nicht daran denkt dass
sie vielleicht irgendwie auch selbst
Zivilcourage jetzt verhalten das klingt
ja ganz groß aber einfach aufmerksam ist
wo wird jemand angegriffen wird dieser
Person geholfen hat sie Fluchtwege das
passiert halt nicht weil wir eben
unterscheiden wir haben so ein
Sicherheitsdenken in der Gesellschaft
wenn Sicherheit da ist dann muss doch
Sicherheit da sein wenn die Sicherheit
einbricht dann haben wir auch kein
Konzept dafür warum das so passiert und
dass wir vielleicht selbst etwas für die
Sicherung von anderen tun sollen
zivilcourage ist nicht ein für alle Mal
da und sie fällt auch nicht vom Himmel
sondern das etwas was wir lernen müssen
und gerade in großen modernen
Gesellschaften öffentlichen Räumen wo
wir alles offen haben wollen ist das
eben noch viel mehr von Nöten ich sehe
in den Kommentaren dass es aber auch so
ein bisschen ganz konkrete Fragen gibt
jemand wollte zum Beispiel wissen würden
bodycams etwas helfen sind es viele
kleine Bausteine die wir trotzdem noch
dazu brauchen wie sehen sie dieses Thema
also bodycams haben in Amerika ein
Untersuchung zunächst mal gezeigt dass
das Tragen von bodycams die Lust diese
bodycams bei Polizeien wegzureißen und
Polizei in anzugreifen und darauf
einzuschlagen zugenommen hat so einfach
ist das nicht weil die Camps müssen
eingeführt werden wir brauchen da eine
Transparenz wie funktioniert eigentlich
sicher halt viele Menschen verstehen
nicht wie Sicherheit funktioniert
sondern sie nehmen das irgendwie wahr
als etwas was ihnen fremd ist Polizei
Einsätze da haben wir im Bereich den
Fußballstadien bei der vielen Gewalt der
80er Jahre viel gemacht durch neue Form
von Polizei einsetzen also alleine nur
auf Sicherheitstechnik zu setzen oder
auch öffentliche Überwachung wir wissen
aus Großbritannien dass diese massive
öffentliche Überwachung durch Kameras
die Gewalt allein nicht mindert sondern
Menschen sich daran gewöhnen und
gewaltbereite die eben mit Gewalt
Gewinne über Raum über andere Menschen
ziehen wollen stören sich nicht daran
also das brauchten umfassendes Konzept
und ich denke die Idee über Alternativen
nachzudenken wir haben am Anfang den
Feuerwehrmann gehört er hat gesagt naja
in anderen Ländern funktioniert das doch
da sollten wir uns beraten lassen wie
das da funktioniert
Prävention von Gewalt braucht ganz
unterschiedliche Maßnahmen und die
allererste Maßnahme ist die in der
nächsten Silvesternacht wir wissen nun
wo Gewalt leichter passieren kann wo es
leichter eskalieren kann da müssen
alternatives Raumkonzept her denn selbst
in Berlin haben wir gesehen an manchen
Stellen funktioniert es vollkommen
friedlich geht es glimpflich ab und
bestimmte Räume sind attraktiv für
Gruppen dort für Unruhe zu sorgen und da
müssen anderes Konzept her
Raumkonzepte zu Silvester fordern sie
aber jetzt auch ganz allgemein eben zu
dieser großen Gewalt steigenden Gewalt
gegenüber Einsatzkräften wo sehen Sie da
auch jetzt natürlich eine Reaktion oder
eine Verantwortung der Politik was muss
aus der Politik auch kommen
na die Politik muss sich natürlich
schützend da vorstellen das wird wird
sie auch tun aber ich glaube wir
brauchen einen umfassende Beschäftigung
mit der Frage der Gewalt in der
Gesellschaft denn die die hasstaten die
aufgrund von bestimmten Vorurteilen
stere Typen menschenfeindlichkeiten
basieren ist in Deutschland doch relativ
hoch und wir müssen auch überlegen wir
haben ja nicht nur diese Form von jetzt
sichtbarer manifester Gewalt das sind
Feuerlöscher auf den Fahrzeug geworfen
wird das direkt geschossen wird auf
Einsatzkräfte das wird werden Raketen
dir auch geschossen auf andere Gruppen
die in einem öffentlichen Raum sind
nicht nur die Rettungskräfte und die
Ordnungsdienste wurden angegriffen
sondern da wurden auch Personen aus der
Zivilbevölkerung beschossen und wir
müssen uns beschäftigen mit den
unterschiedlichen Facetten von Gewalt in
der Gesellschaft
mit der Gewalt die dann in Social Media
weiter historisiert wird da werden
richtige
Videos hochgeladen werden Geschichten
aufgesattelt wir brauchen eine deutliche
Aufarbeitung von welch von den
unterschiedlichsten Formen der Gewalt
und Fragen auch der Gewaltprävention der
gehört die Beleidigung dazu dass
anpöbeln dazu all diese
unterschiedlichen Facetten müssen wir
verstehen und Gruppendynamiken viel
ernster nehmen wir haben zunehmend eben
Gruppen die durch die Städte ziehen die
immer wieder sich zeigen und da brauchen
wir auch Konzept um an die Gruppen nah
dran zu kommen und zu überlegen wie
können wir Konflikte stärker managen
also das kommunale Management von Gewalt
und Konflikten spielt eine große Rolle
da gibt es Kommunen die stellen sich gut
auf die haben die Kapazitäten Politik
muss jetzt gucken wo fehlen eigentlich
Kapazitäten nicht nur in den
Rettungsdiensten Ordnung sondern auch
bei den Kommunen was brauchen wissen Sie
eigentlich um eine gute Gewaltprävention
zu machen
sagt Professor Dr Andreas Zick vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
heute abend ich danke Ihnen
viele von euch teilen das gesagt auch
ich habe hier ein Kommentar gesehen
Verbote sind der falsche Weg das zieht
die vernünftigen vollen Mitleidenschaft
hier muss man viel mehr an die Ursachen
ran und zwar ohne diese schön zu reden
an die Ursachen das sagte auch Professor
Dr Andreas Zick das habe ich von euch
gelesen und ich habe auch gesehen dass
viele von euch selbst tätig sind in der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr selbst als
Einsatzkräfte und natürlich zurecht
folgendes Schreiben wie Sascha Schäfer
wann werden wir als Feuerwehr besser
geschützt vor Gewalt gegen uns ich
möchte Leben retten und anderen helfen
aber ich möchte nicht verletzt werden
bei meiner Arbeit natürlich nicht und
das wird uns demnach wahrscheinlich auch
noch weiter beschäftigen wir bleiben für
euch dran und jetzt erstmal danke für
heute euer Interesse und einen schönen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]